I like doing a curveball at the
beginning if someone is actually never
seen anything that either of you have
done before what is the first thing
you'd like them watching and why it's a
great question that is a really great
question
you're very thoughtful uh
wow
for me I think it'd have to be do the
right thing because it was just such a
film that changed the course of history
for African Americans who were wanting
and Desiring to see positive images of
themselves on the screen I was working
with a great artist Spike Lee and
because of my energetic performances
bugging out someone who wanted to know
the history of what happened that went
before him but didn't quite know at all
but still wanted to be an activist so it
plays into my provocative nature of
wanting people to see that side of me
um I think for me it would be Sabrina
um because Prudence is a character it
was just it was a really fun character
for me to build
um and and my first time my first time
playing a villain ever
um our villainous type character
um and I I'm very proud of the way that
I was able to add layers to Prudence
um and was able to humanize her through
her being this
um excuse my French for this you know
[ __ ] sort of character
um
and
yeah I think that it's
it's a good introduction to me and to
show where I came from as far as being
an actor and because I took a lot of my
theater training into prudence
um
and
yeah it was it it's similarly it's a
character that I took a lot of energy to
um and that has a lot of energy so yeah
I would choose Prudence jumping into why
I get to talk to you guys today one of
the crazy things about this series is
you can watch it in any order and I'm
just curious if you want to suggest an
order to people or sort of the way it
pops up on Netflix I would want people
to to watch it and how it pops up on
Netflix
um I definitely would not suggest an
order
um because I'm very excited and curious
to see
um or to hear the conversations that
come out of everybody seeing it in a
different way
um and just excited to hear what people
take from their particular uh set
um so yeah I would not suggest any order
I would have to agree I think the magic
of this is to watch it in the color of
scheme that appeals to you uh certainly
um if it pops up on Netflix in a
suggested order I would say jumble that
order and just go for one because no
matter which order you watch this
particular show in you're gonna watch it
again in a different order because
you're going to be intrigued enough to
want to see how all these puzzle pieces
fit with each other and how the
connective tissue of all these
characters gives you a different way in
each time you watch it uh one of the
things about the series I love uh movies
and shows that show heists and this show
obviously has a big Heist
um so what is it like being part of
something like you know like it's cool
it's a great genre
to me I think it's a wonderful genre and
I think the uh this Heist will be the
ultimate Heist because it gets
heightened because you don't actually
know that you're going to see all of it
or you see all of it but then you start
to see it from a different angle and you
realize oh this happened in between this
and this so I think this is the ultimate
Heist piece I'll just say that uh and I
think for me to do it I was just like I
felt like I was on a completely new
adventure because what I have to do in
this ice is pretty freaking amazing I
I'm not only the Mastermind of the heist
which by the way is based on a heist
place during Hurricane Sandy uh years
ago of 70 billion dollars in unsecured
bearer bonds that was never solved not
only am I the Mastermind of that but I
also what I have to do to exact a
certain kind of revenge on someone that
you will eventually find out in many
different permutations of the Eight
Episodes that I'm after is kind of
amazing and so when you watch it just
know that I did all of that
do you want to add anything
sorry yeah sure
um so uh
I I mean I'm just excited to be part of
the heist genre in this way
um because it's one it's thrilling it
and by having these characters that are
um uh Giancarlo used a really great term
earlier these every man sort of
characters it gives the audience this
thrill the things that we all you know
wish that we could we could try one day
or or wish that we could tap into
um and similarly to
I think the twists of this Heist
um is what makes it so incredible and
makes it the ultimate Heist
um because it's it's not not just okay
you have a team they're after this they
get it there they go there's a bit more
uh idiosyncrasy and
who you think might win is probably not
who's gonna win
um and so
yeah uh I think that this Heist is I
think that Eric did an incredible Eric
in our whole writing team that just did
an incredible job of throwing you with
the heist that it's it'll be like no
Heist experience you've had before uh
before I run out of time Giancarlo I do
have to ask you an individual question
um I was just in Brazil at ccxp and they
showed a pretty good Sizzle reel of the
Mandalorian season three and I saw I
mean it looks insane with action tons of
mandalorians teasing Mandalore it
basically I don't know if you've seen
the sizzle but it looks massive the
season and so I have to ask you how is
season three compared to the previous
ones
um what can you what can you say about
it I just think that the show gets more
expanded and and and more visually
um uh profound with each season uh and I
think it's the vision of John Favreau
and John poloney's uh David filoni
certainly that that begins that
expansion but but it's also all of The
Artisans that they a trust to
collaborate with them I was blown away
by that civil real all of a sudden the
world just came at you uh in in a much
more intense and and it's always been
gratifying uh but in a way that allowed
you to know you know that feeling that
you have of dread or Doom or excitement
personified that's the feeling you get
because the story is is all of a sudden
being coalesced for you to understand
there are other elements elements that
you didn't know about and and and so I
love the mythology that goes behind this
show is incorporated into the visuals
that seem to be filmic and I I love the
fact that you're able to see with each
episode this season you're really
turning on a new movie uh visually it's
a Sight and Sound Extravaganza that
expands you to a place that look there
we we can say a lot of words
about a lot of different things just
like Kaleidoscope but I think when you
watch it you have the space
to feel emotion and connection between
character
Mandalorian you have the space to feel
the largest of this universe of this
World building and you have the space to
see where you fit in
God I wish I could be that Warrior that
hero that heroine and we see the
weakness and and the power of the the
the villainous who want for themselves
and not for the whole what I love about
this show it is about our army is about
all of us
who are starting to understand once
again it's for the people and by the
people and if we stand up and allow our
voices to be heard and understand their
strength in numbers we can then recreate
the world as it should be in peace
Harmony and creatively scientifically
and politically a way for us to
understand that there are no borders
anymore and so Mandalorian exemplifies
all of that this season is off the chain
and you're gonna love it on that note I
need to stop I'm just going to say
congrats on this series to both of you
and I wish you guys nothing but the best
thank you so much